buongiorno sono usciti nuovi livelli
quando fai un quindi andremo a vedere
assieme come solo alla fine del video
potrebbe scriversi quale è stato il boss
scherzo preferito anche noi vi diremo in
un occhio scelto preferito e ora il
giovane vi piace fa per scoprire che
personaggio siete oggi cliccate mi piace
48 e l'ultima cifra del vostro mi piace
corrisponde al vostro personaggio qua mi
è capitato se volete scrivetelo nei
commenti dei nomi seguiti ancora senza
casa
mettetevi comodi come sempre pop corn e
iniziamo il gico hanno stupito per il
primo scherzo anni bsb un cerchietto con
i pali è il primo schermo come vedete
c'è già il nuovo capitolo qui disse che
se da che cosa
aurora stato un uomo di posta di scary
teaser con il costume da carica che ha
un nuovo aggiornamento abbiamo visto
vedendo le immagini mi viene da ridere
promo di morte ticket.it se voleva fare
uno scherzo del primo aprile stesso
aprile ai ragazzi
assicuriamoci che questo scherzo
dimenticherò mai e verrà fatto a lei ora
non si è capito che cosa ha detto
scritti da loro ci eravamo noi c'era
league e tanino con fernando stavamo
escogitando qualcosa forse un nuovo
schermo in inglese perché lì parlava
appunto del pesce d'aprile che ci vuole
fare a noi quindi lei si deve fare una
scelta e noi stiamo realizzando per fare
uno scherzo a lei è praticamente dice li
dobbiamo fare uno scherzo alla torta
giusti qua allora prove dominare su di
domenica
mettiamo una bomba o qualcosa che la
face brother guarda allora qui abbiamo
una cassaforte c'è già una bomba o no
una brutta dinamite troviamo il filo
rosso scambio i frutti sulla torta sono
io né scontro con tumore non è
aggiornato e vitale per fare quello che
dite
la rubata se nome sulla carta porta
quindi noi prendiamo i mirtilli che sono
qui non lo so forse dobbiamo trovare
un'altra torta proviamo a vedere i legni
arrivati o no adesso dirà santis da
sacco di cose che non hanno senso
inseriti scettico perché mette la
tordela cassaforte sono detto perché
roma la mangiamo io ti amo invece due
torte protagonista dobbiamo prendere le
fragole e mettere i mirtilli qui di che
colore era d'altra torta l'ha notato che
era l'altra torta ve lo ricordate
c'è qualcosa guarda si sa come si vede
neanche fossero de coreana più che dire
il colore di quella torta forse ua
diciamo un altro guardate cos'è non è
bastata carroccio quindi dobbiamo ancora
relatore numerata questo il rosso forse
l'altra era rosa di più quindi forse
dobbiamo e viaria nemo rota lo sappiamo
benissimo da tutti gli frega che abbiamo
un mago
e stata possibile stai attento perché
lei si sta avvicinando sta tenendo crimi
non altro che vediamo è finita dobbiamo
portare tutti ok adesso andiamo su
abbiamo trascurato corpo attenzione
perché lo ora lei siccome sa visto che
siamo sentiti alla cucina con la torta
andrà a controllare il nome era l'altra
torto adesso non mi ricordo era di
quanti forte ecco qui ce la dobbiamo
invertire la torta aspetta che faccia né
sotto per questo lo mettiamo qui lo
lasciamo qui per terra allora prima le
fragole qui ok ok
noi mettiamo la decorazione rosa ok
adesso dice di invertire le torte guarda
ok quindi questa la mettiamo nella
cassaforte
chiudiamo la porta così lei non se ne
accorge
ok e poi scendiamo giù ma forse lei
ancora non se n'è accorto sta salendo
qui io do per fortuna non se ne forte di
musina allora adesso dobbiamo solo
mettere la torta qui e poi scappare nè
che chiediamo il trio già finito
ma non sarà accorto o scappato gioco
ci sto per un pezzo di torta
[Applauso]
il libero va a farsi lo scherzo con una
sorta ma noi l'abbiamo invertita e c'era
un telecomando lanciare in aria
forse c'era un radiocomando nella torta
lei l'ha mangiata ea la tratta su
sull'aeroporto come mangiano scorsa ha
preso una pista di toyako la faccia il
gioco di parole in inglese guidhall
spendono laggiù è non solo mani come
tradurlo comunque un gioco di parole con
le piume sarà quindi assicuriamo si
chiede la festa di pasqua di scary
teacher sia un congresso
no no vabbè
[Musica]
non ci credo il fidanzato di spiriti cra
fatto che ri teaser di ciò che è stato
di zucchero perché inseriti jarque è
sempre cattivissima conferenze su
persevera a vivo per chiudere il suo
uovo di pasqua detto sta scendendo
attiva l'area condizionare target per i
teaser di cioccolato quindi chissà come
saranno sicuramente da fare uno show si
concentravano le piume e salt c'è
parlava di piume anche io ho preso
qualcosa di nuovo qui nel garage
ho preso una chiave inglese una manopola
una pinza trovo un qualcosa per cercare
di distruggere la statua di cioccolato
di miss ti arrabbiare tantissimo ho
trovato questo termosifone allora dice
aumentare il riscaldamento si esatto con
la nonna dobbiamo mettere questo qui e
poi dobbiamo aumentare la temperatura
ok adesso dice di aumentare la
temperatura adesso dice che dobbiamo
andare e ma non meno male nell'aria che
conta
macef razzista ci sono date krumm e qui
forse dobbiamo sostituire il cuscino di
piume dato che abbiamo ricominciato
tutto riposto il tutto e ora stiamo
cercando il tecnico per qui piscina in
piscina di almeno dobbiamo svegliare
francis francis
adesso dobbiamo sostituire guarda che ti
dice prendila i primi cuscino piano
piano abbiamo preso cerca di prendere ll
più menano cuscino
ecco qui c'è un coltello prendiamo il
coltello trova un modo di prendere le
piume della tuscia si allora adesso
dobbiamo trovare qualcosa per metterle
ok abbiamo preso il secchio guarda
stiamo mettendo le più belle al secchio
adesso dice metti le piume nell'aria
condizionata
guardate lei sta curando la sua statua
di cioccolato non possiamo andare lì a
rate ok allora abbiamo trovato la stanza
chiudiamo la porta così non si scopre
come sempre ci permetterà di se ora di
di scappare di non lasciare nessuna
traccia e via attento ai lasciato
qualcosa che non lo so si no tu non
abbiamo fatto in tempo a torino noto
ancora la manopola viorica viaggiato
tutta la calabria che usiamo la gran
persona anche bisogna fare togliere la
manopola così con la pinza fare il fiume
del climatizzatore adesso finalmente
possiamo scappare
scivolata perché praticamente tutto il
cioccolato si è sciolto è andato per
terre le è scivolata in fiamme tre
ammazzo minacciose che disperata ha
regalato è mica uno scherzo ma allora
scritti cer pensava di poter imbrogliare
alla caccia al tesoro
assicuriamoci che lei vada nella strada
sbagliata nella direzione sbagliata
vediamo allora finiti te l'ha detto a
francis di scavare delle buche e di non
fermarsi mai finché mettiamo di ceneri e
quindi ha scavato dalle 20 santana sotto
terra perché lei male ha detto si ferma
la andiamo a prendere i nostri attrezzi
nella casetta in cui ci sono tutti gli
attrezzi lucani scritti sarò adottato un
cane
vediamolo da vicino sibile non passare
tedesco sta facendo la guardia una
casetta da una catena d'oro al collo e
si darti piano piano attento
non penso che ci seguono allora mi metto
lì a controllare un abito quindi spiriti
c'era preso un cane per fare la guardia
così non cosa mi fa venire alla casetta
degli atti ne possono fare non è cosa
per fare gli scherzi ai furbetti ma
dobbiamo trovare il modo di registrare
il tale prima casa dentro
devo trovare un rosso in cucina ma stare
poi dopo dobbiamo anche salvarlo perché
non possiamo lanciare quel potrò con la
maestra cattiva vi ricordate come tra
stava il gatto nero non l'avete vista
andate a vedere gli altri soldi quindi
cerchiamo un osso in cui ci ne vediamo
questo stiamo tutti la brava è un paese
mercati ok se non avete il cibo al che
c'e la sua cuccia speriamo così di
distrarlo
ok adesso devo di numerosi c è che
dobbiamo fare guarda che sta restando
carati bisogna aspettare che lui passati
e fuori o no sta andando a ok sapere
lecce di roma ecco il cane sta arrivando
è un pastore tedesco visto io ho paura
però se salgono sopra lui se ne accorge
che sta venendo qui guarda che cai
rapporto da un mese sicuri per dare a
noi
no noi siamo noi lo distraiamo proviamo
ad andare a vivere
[Musica]
dice fai a tormentare il cane vedi
prendi la chiave quando il cane dorme
con la chiave ha detto a chiare note a
tutti non ce la faccio dobbiamo trovare
dei sonniferi per far addormentare il
cane così possiamo prendere la chiave
che forse è quella che al collo e si
doveva prelevare con gli esami sanitari
che immettiamo legislazione speriamo che
mangi questa volta forse dobbiamo
allontanarci appreso ok abbiamo rifatto
il livello da capo questa volta
metteremo il cibo per cani assieme
estoni ferì nello stesso momento
così forse riusciamo il cane andrò a
maggio la giornata di test hanno già
raggiunto presentato vediamo corredo
visivo la chiave piano piano senza fare
troppo rumore
si ok allora dice che apriremo di aprire
l'occhietto del garage che ora possiamo
aprire la porta ora come allora dobbiamo
manipolare la ma attenzione perché
scritti c'era in giardino proprio non se
ne accorga
proviamo così vediamo se funziona si no
c'è scoperto che ho mai letto
abbiamo rifatto il livello tutto daccapo
e abbiamo visto che l'aics va a messa
nella fauna ora dovrebbe funzionare
eccolo abbiamo riferito abbiamo fatta
carne come è stato un altro scherzo
proposito di premi libera colore l'aereo
il tuo è il mio quella della statuetta
di cioccolato che siciliano di piume e
ora andate a vedere i nostri altri è
bisogno di spiriti siano pure cliccate
nella casellina che preferite e buona
visione
ciao